but does that get my does that get my
rocks off yeah it does dude it gets my
rocks off
is that what you're asking me Anthony
[Music]
here we go not a lot to this one but
this is where you guys riff all right
this is where you breathe you might have
seen this the wreath all right there was
a hotel manager who's been accused of
entering a guest room and sucking on his
toes I heard about that I was asleep
I've been seeing that everywhere that's
called a circle that's just high level
service isn't that called rape
I think it's called non-consensual
sexual harassment maybe yeah okay that
sounds super politically correct okay
I thought it was just called sneaky oral
reflexology nice yeah or is that labeled
as molestation that's molestation
molestology I think
the
managerologist my name is what's your
sign oh you're Greek
yeah
stupid so wait why are you why do you
support this huh why do you why are you
on the side that supports this oh no
well you said it was two guys right he
said it was great service it's two guys
good service dude that's [__] maybe
he caught a Vibe and he thought like hey
dude he's read the room wrong he just
read the rumor yeah did he get in
trouble because it was unwanted or it
turned out bad or like you know in my
head I'm like dude it's just toes how do
you yeah all right how does one not know
if someone sneaks in their room yeah
yeah yeah you hear the little beep of
the key card I feel a tongue on I tell
him I wake up real quick yeah bro what
if that happened to you I'd be really
upset I'd be very would you file a
complaint unless he was like no this is
just good service and I'd be like oh my
bad yeah well could he immediately do to
make up for it is that the liquor you
gotta let me that's the sucker no that's
[__] that's Stephen King
oh that's the hotel manager bro that guy
looks all kinds of creepy what kind of
Hotel was this he looks like he's going
I don't see what the big deal was he
just sucked on his toes he liked it
missed mixed up Hotel [__] gives me
weird Vibes yeah I had a um we had like
uh we sponsored like a really big power
lifting event one year and then we our
plane got um delayed so we arrived late
at night and it was I think it's one of
those where like the event was way too
big for the city so you can tell this
isn't clean Texas so like the the city
was like very very small and like they
don't handle like big things so
everything is like very mom and pop like
it almost like oh [__] I need a ride
somewhere oh just come take my car you
know yeah
um I don't think that Sheraton's
supposed to do that it's supposed to be
like oh like I'll call you a car like
there's like formalities that you do we
got there late and then um they're like
they're like oh we're here to check in
into our hotels and they gave me and
like two other people room keys we go in
the room and we open it and we oh
there's like people sleeping on the
floor on the bed and stuff and then
we're like
what the [__] because there's like two
uh at midnight we close the door we go
back and then we're like oh um that's I
don't think that's the right rooms
because there's people in there and he's
like no no that's the right one that's
the right one I'm not like no it's not
can we get switch it out this guy had to
go with us to the room
and open it again just to double check
you're lying so imagine imagine
use your room and you're like what the
[__] why is there somebody opening the
door once you're like okay that must
have been a mistake could you close
don't go back to sleep and you're like
what the [__] they're [__] opening it
again it's like Monsters Inc because
when you open it the second time it's
somewhere else you're like okay now it's
the empty room my back and then she
would open it twice yeah but like even
me going into someone else's room
because I know that's their space I felt
like I invaded their space and it fell
he felt weird I felt like you would have
like just got into beds like
good night
they said go to sleep here we're gonna
power lift tomorrow
are you also here for the events
that's weird that you have to prove it
to them yeah well you didn't believe
Bart he's like this Chinese guy doesn't
know what he's talking about yeah it
looks weird man was he Asian no it was
like this really nice black dude oh okay
I was gonna say because I went to Asian
restaurant once and I was like Hey the
soda's too flat and they're like no it's
not yeah I was like yeah it is like and
then she was pissed she walked away she
looked left she looked right
and then she kept him walking he's like
oh she drank my drink she had to find
out prove a point yeah she paused she
drink it and then she walked forward and
they got me a new tree I was like dick
she didn't believe me he agreed with you
but silently yeah on her way to our room
there was a [__] baby rattlesnake in
the hallway no way yeah because like I'm
just telling this town is like way too
small for what's going on and then like
the workers are freaking out or whatever
what do we do what do we do and the deem
came with um a [__] broom or
something and he killed it on the spot
killed a baby they're poisonous you know
allegedly the more poisonous right it's
like fresh Venom yeah like yikes it was
just like a whole just a [__] show of a
weekend dude Nadine's kind of a gangster
this kind of gangster yeah well this guy
what he did he's uh his name is David
Neal put him on blast age 52. he cloned
a geek a key card in order to get in so
I must admit that he had like he like
eyed this dude out he checked in looked
at him with his x-ray vision through his
[__] shoes and socks and was like you
tonight yeah yeah and close the key card
for the specific room shows up in the
middle of the night and then this dude
wakes up to the guy's sucking his toes
he said I instantly jumped up and was
screaming went into a sort of
fact-finding mode who are you why are
you in my room what are you doing here I
could see he was wearing a uniform he
had his name tag on he was talking to me
but wasn't giving me any substantive
answers yo whenever they find stuff like
this it's like the perfect situation
where there's no way this is the only
thing this guy's ever done oh
you think this guy David he was kind of
red footage
what happened you think this guy's kind
of lonely
David Neal wait what does the victim
look like is he like super handsome
David Neal's the victim dude wait is he
no oh
in a way he is yeah yeah yeah
this guy might be a hottie though is he
I feel like he's working the night shift
of the hotel and then he's just bored
too maybe yeah what's the name of this
hotel what does the hotel look like is
it nice is it like a Ramada it's a
Hilton
is it a Double Tree wait yeah because
Hilton's it's not double cheese
what kind of service are you talking
about here you know is DoubleTree the
better one the best I don't know that's
a business one that's where like Out of
Towners come and stay because what are
the different ones there's there's a
regular one that doesn't have a name
right and then there's Double Tree then
aren't there like two others I don't
know something by Hilton yeah Courtyard
Marriott Courtyard Courtyard
yeah that's not even Hilton you know you
were just saying though
[Laughter]
rubbish straight rubbish
you know you were saying that you would
walk it you walked into that room when
you weren't supposed to you already felt
like I felt weird yeah yeah versus like
somebody else who does that feels
[__] turned on yeah that's weird
honestly sometimes people feel curious I
think I'd feel curious or is he doing it
for an adrenaline rush is he doing it
for like getting caught it's probably
like cool with him he's like yeah it was
worth it I'll do it again David Neal
probably just a little [__] up in his
head you know a little bit I want to see
what the signs were they go back to his
life right what led up to the second
yeah like what other things did this guy
do that's a movie The sucking of the toe
he for sure was turned on by this dude
when he checked in he was like yeah he
scoped around the lobby for sure yeah
bro he wrote his name down he was like
hold on what's your name what room are
you in cool okay would you like a
fluffing service sir
not like somebody leaves a sock behind
in the room he like picks it up sniffs
it oh it's wet yeah
dude a random toe sucking on a random
toes wild Bro [__] yeah especially a
dude's toe I've seen some guy's toes and
you have two probably wrong where on the
mats where you're like I don't know if
you should be stepping on the map yeah
it looks like a Frosted Flake yeah bro
like some were so yellow we were just
like dude whoa and I think most
obviously you're rolling I don't even
want to suck on my own toe that's what
I'm saying like it's all jammed up it's
not just jammed up like your toenail
discolors yeah like it's like you could
tell there's fungus you know but does
that get my does that get my rocks off
yeah it does dude it gets when it rocks
off
is that what you're asking me Anthony
[Laughter]
yeah bro I'm right here baby have you
guys ever seen dry aged steak yeah it's
on the crust they call it the pellicle
yeah they cut that part off yeah that's
what some toenails look like
sick I'm getting nauseous guys okay keep
going
so if this guy's on death row and
they're like what do you what's your
last meal he's like get me that guy's
toe well do they have to do it I think
they have to they go hey bro sorry man
but you gotta go back convention hi this
is the prison uh this man is about to
die yeah his last kiss is sucking your
toe which one they're all I know you
hate this guy you got a history but he's
gonna die man come on if you're a tall
guy does that mean you could suck
someone's toes so much until you jizz on
yourself is that how that works I don't
know yeah I think we're back to that
yeah we're back we're back to like
wondering how these Kinks work yeah yeah
I like how it even starts yeah yeah I've
been hearing a lot of foot fetishes like
over the past few years it's been really
weird they're really coming out the
woodwork my teammate Carla Esparza
um former UFC uh world champion yeah she
was uh I think she was ranked number one
or top 10 prettiest feet in MMA wow
really yep dead serious wow I hope she
made a killing off that I hope she sold
some feet pics I don't know that's what
they do that's what these people do to
monetize a lot of Fighters have only
fans for just defeat yeah really yeah
good idea about a girl a girl fighters I
don't know about guys but they're like
they're showing their feet all the time
on the [__] yeah but you can't get a
good look dude
you know what that means it's like the
the rain is so high for people that are
into that there's probably a ton of
people watching this that are listening
to us going what's a big deal yeah dude
I heard human talk about it and he was
talking about how it's like associated
with people don't get turned on or get
kicked out by things that are like
positive necessarily like the your feet
are like meant to be dirty you know what
I mean because you walk around the
bottom of the floor you know so like it
gets dirty so I think people because of
that because it's not normalized they
like poop they like pee you know it's
something that's like yeah Dirty Feet
pickle toe yeah
I think that's the reason why people
like it is because it's like it's kind
of shown to be in a negative light for
good reason that's why I love feet
that's why I like poop poop come on dude
that's the Holy Trinity that's what we
call it
foreign